what's going on guys axel beats here for
anime uproar and today we're going to be
covering some of the most powerful
characters in one piece these being the
19 users of conquerors hockey these
characters are one in several million
cases of people born with qualities of
kings supreme rulers who are able to
exert their wills on other people but
before we get into that video you guys
know the drill if you're enjoying the
one piece content on the channel
remember to leave a like and a comment
down below and of course if you haven't
taken the time to subscribe to the
channel that is the best way to support
us and keep up to date with our content
not to mention it's absolutely free so
it's a win-win finally this video will
probably cover some manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned before we get into the
actual characters who have conquerors
haki we should probably talk about what
conquerors hockey is especially since it
can often feel like conquerors is the
most ambiguous kind of all haki like
with observation and armament there
tends to be a very clear thing happening
boosting the user's ability to perceive
the world around it or bolstering the
attack and defense of the people using
it or their weapons but what does it
really mean to impose your will on
others at a base level this just means
that your willpower or your desire to
see your dream come true is stronger in
comparison to the will of your target
and the bigger that gap the stronger the
effect of your conquerors hockey will be
which is why we often see this ability
taking shape in those who have roles of
leadership or who have deep-seated
dreams that they're trying to make a
reality it is those who aim to change
the world who have the strongest wills
and that's what makes them natural
leaders and that tends to be a common
thread between conquerors users they
have the ability to lead dominate or
guide those around them in terms of how
this ability actually manifests it's
fairly unique unlike observation and
armament this is an ability that you
have to be born with and it's unable to
be taught or trained the only way to
actually develop conquerors haki is to
generally become stronger both in body
and in spirit this means that the more
capable someone is the more they're able
to conquer and that kind of makes sense
this also means that while children can
manifest conker's hockey like ace did
it's usually pretty mild in their hands
and doesn't fully take shape until
they're adults once it does develop
though it tends to be used in four
different ways these are domination
incapacitation pressure and infusion at
least those are the titles given to them
in the one piece wiki and honestly
they're pretty fitting i don't believe
i've heard these names used in the
actual series but we're gonna go with
them for ease of access domination is
the ability to intimidate or subdue
others we typically see this being used
against animals and it is the first
example of hockey that we saw in the
series with shanks scaring off the king
of the coast
it's more about scaring or stopping
things that you don't really want to
hurt for example luffy uses this against
motobotto or tsurume as they're just
animals and they don't really deserve to
be beaten up but even so their rampages
do need to be stopped that said we do
also see this being used against
non-animals as well for example when
luffy is fighting the gorgon sisters he
uses it to stop them from destroying the
statues of his new friends on amazon
lily what's interesting is that both of
these two obviously have zone fruits so
while they themselves are not animals
they are influenced by animal traits at
least that's what luchi had explained
when he was talking about how his fruit
affects him incapacitation is the next
level up we aren't just trying to stop
an animal rampaging and we don't
particularly care about the people that
we're targeting so instead of just
scaring them we're knocking them out
this is first seen when shanks walks
onto whitebeard's ship and like half of
his crew passes out as a result when
this is used by luffy he's typically
surrounded by a large group of enemies
and thus this will thin their numbers
pretty considerably a conqueror doesn't
just impose himself on the living things
around him though it can also damage the
surrounding environment as well and this
is pressure we also see this when shanks
gets onto the moby dick as he not only
knocks out whitebeard's crew but you can
also see damage to the ship as well more
noticeably though is when two conqueror
users clash and the pressure begins to
spark sending out black lightning and
also producing shockwaves that can push
back whatever's around them if the users
are particularly powerful these
shockwaves can even divide the clouds
above them in the sky and finally the
newest form of conqueror's hockey that
we know of being infusion by imbuing
their weapons and bodies with haki they
can boost their attacks in a more
impactful way i know this isn't exactly
right but i like to think of it as a
kind of fusion of armament and
conquerors this is actually significant
enough of a boost to allow luffy to even
make meaningful hits on kaido when only
armament alone wasn't leaving any damage
this is one of the most rare elements of
conquerors even among the only 19 users
that we know of just seven of them are
able to use infusion at least that we've
seen so far these being roger whitebeard
kaido luffy big mom yamato and zorro now
speaking of let's talk about all the
known users of conkers and to keep them
a little bit organized we're going to be
dividing them into four groups firstly
the legends people who have challenged
the world and came back as champions
mostly of the previous era of pirates
these include goldie roger edward
newgate kozuki odin don qin zhao silver
israeli kaido and big mom we can also
probably throw sengoku into the mix and
on that note it's pretty interesting to
mention that he's the only marine to
ever have shown conquerors hockey in the
series i'm not sure why it's so slanted
towards pirates but if i had to guess it
might be something in line with about
how marines are part of a chain of
command and unless you're at the top
you're not really conquering or
controlling anything moving on we have a
few characters who are in their prime
right now who aren't quite in the old
guard but aren't quite in the new guard
either these being shanks doflamingo and
katakuri and from here we can move on to
the next generation of conquerors
including monkey d luffy rory noah zorro
yamato portuguese d ace eustis kidd and
boa hancock
finally there are two non-canon users in
douglas bullet and naguri i highly doubt
that these are the only characters who
have conquerors in the series and likely
there are a few characters that we've
already met that we just don't know
about if i had to guess i'd probably
look at characters like dragon zabic
blackbeard sakazuki imusama and joyboy
all likely being conker's users as well
of course we also have characters to
mention like garp and mihawk but to me
those two don't quite give off the
conqueror's vibe if that makes sense
both of them are just kind of too
content with where they are and aren't
exactly ambitiously working towards a
goal they just don't show off that drive
or ambition to grow or to spread their
influence that's often associated with
congress law as well kind of fits in
this boat as he is definitely ambitious
but he doesn't really feel like he's
confident enough to give off that i can
do anything mentality especially when
you compare him to characters like luffy
or kid for example he instead prefers to
strategize or lean on others like luffy
to make his goals a reality and at this
point you might be asking well what
about characters like zoro or yamato who
have conquerors but aren't the leaders
of their crew and to that we have to
point out that they directly rank under
other people who do have conquerors in
fact every case of a conqueror's user
who isn't the head honcho is directly
subservient to someone who also has
conquerors sort of a king's only respect
king's mentality i guess as marigold and
treble both explained throughout the
series these characters have qualities
of kings it isn't about them literally
being royals or nobles the bloodline
just doesn't matter but instead it's all
about ambition that said by the time
that many of these people's lives or
adventures ended they would also gain
some kind of title or epithet that would
be a symbol of their conquering roles so
let's talk about what these conquerors
did and how they earned their titles
gold d roger was the captain of the
first crew since the void century to
successfully make it all the way to the
end of the grand line finding laughtale
and earning the title of pirate king his
rival edward newgate became a yonko who
held influence over a ton of islands and
nations by leading a pirate crew of over
1600 members and it wasn't just his crew
though newgate himself was also given
the titles of strongest man in the world
and the man closest to finding the one
piece even holding those titles despite
how unhealthy he had become in his old
age
the true show of newgate's dominance
though is his ability to make the entire
world call him whitebeard even though he
only had a mustache speaking of insanely
powerful people kozuki odin the man who
would conquer the region of curry which
had previously been filled with exiled
outlaws pillagers and murderers just all
around not a fun place some of these
outlaws include people like kinemon
rhizo kanjuro kikunojo kawamatsu denjiro
and ashura doji and those names matter
quite a bit considering that they made
up the majority of the people who would
form odin's red scabbards when he became
daimyo interestingly enough though the
only title that odin would actually be
given is idiot lord by orochi however in
general just his name alone has become
synonymous with legend so it's a pretty
unique situation for sure we all know
how badass odin is but on the complete
opposite side of the spectrum we have
qinzhao let me know in the comments if
anyone actually likes qin zhao because
to me he's just always seemed so
so lame either way though xinjiang was
the 12th leader of the hapo navy they
had collected a massive hoard of gold
under the jeweled ice sheet which was
only accessible due to xinjiao's drill
shaped head this head was flattened by
monkey d garp and later ultimately fixed
by luffy for his position as head of the
xinjiao family and of the hapo navy he
was given the title of don qinzhou as
well for his signature attack he was
given the title xinjiao the drill
rayleigh is pretty interesting as we
don't know a ton of things about him let
alone the specifics of what he really
wanted in his youth other than to help
roger on his voyage what we do know is
that he was the first mate to the king
of the pirates and given the title dark
king and to me at least this implies
that while roger was getting all the
attention and living in the light of
public view rayleigh was likely in
charge of a lot of the background things
helping from the shadows that's just my
theory though since i can't really see
this generally friendly guy like
rayleigh having this ominous sounding
epithet for no reason kaido on the other
hand could definitely earn a name like
that he was the captain of the beast
pirates and now a former yonko ruling
over wano for the last 20 years and
amassing an army of artificial devil
fruit users as well as powerful ancient
zones kaido himself was considered to be
so powerful that in any one-on-one fight
he would always come out on top because
he is more or less unkillable earning
him the title of strongest creature in
the world his former crewmates as well
as fellow former yonko herself charlotte
linlin ruled over the totland
archipelago as well as being a prominent
pirate for the last 60 years much like
kaido linlin would go on to produce her
own personal army although she did it in
a more literal sense aiming to have
children from each race other than
giants and to form a pseudo-peaceful
utopia where all races could belong she
would go on to have 85 children with 43
husbands over the last 42 years and as
such it makes a lot of sense that she
would be called big mom in our last
entry into the new guard we have sengoku
the former fleet admiral of the marines
who was considered to be one of the
strongest marines from rogers generation
going on to lead the marines until their
victory at marine ford against the
whitebeard pirates his strategic mind
earned him the title of the resourceful
general but he also had a much more
straightforward name the buddha which
instead was a reference to the devil
fruit that he used in either vein he's
supposed to be a symbol of wisdom and
guidance among the marines first of our
current age of yonkos is shanks shanks
is another character who is filled with
mysteries but it feels like we're on the
verge of knowing his true intentions
however it would seem that his overall
goal is to stop blackbeard shanks
himself is of course a former apprentice
on rogers crew as well as being the
inspiration for luffy to set sail unlike
the former yonko shanks doesn't have a
title about his strength in fact none of
this generation of yonko do which is
pretty interesting instead he's simply
called red hair shanks that said much
like how odin's name demands respect as
soon as anyone hears red hair they do
jump to it being shanks and like owning
an entire hair color is pretty
impressive in itself doflamingo the only
celestial dragon that we know of with
conquerors haki led the don quixote
pirates ultimately earning a spot as a
warlord and giving him carte blanche
access to conquer dressrosa and become
its king for the last decade all while
he also ruled the underworld under the
codename joker fitting for someone who
would bring smiles to wano finally
doffy's epithet the heavenly demon or
heavenly yasha is in reference to him
being a celestial dragon who now aims to
destroy everything and the last of our
midpoint conquerors is of course
katakuri second son of big mom and one
of her sweet commanders he is considered
to be the strongest member of her crew
and rules over komugi island as its
minister we unfortunately don't know a
lot about where khan curry is going
based on recent manga events but i would
imagine that he's likely going to get a
title based on his actions from this
point on finally on to the new age of
conquerors starting of course with
monkey d luffy captain of the straw hats
and leader of the grand fleet of 5 000
members the man aiming to be the next
pirate king the return of joy boy an
inheritor of both roger's will and the
mythical nika devil fruit he is the
former fifth emperor and current new
yonko and it's pretty straightforward to
see why luffy has conquerors haki when
you consider everything involved around
his character at this point but what is
interesting to note is that luffy is
seemingly the only one on a list who has
no interest in conquering others instead
he has this innate ability to garner the
trust respect and loyalty of anyone
whose path he crosses and he simply
wants to be the most free obviously
luffy's title is straw hat but that
raises some interesting questions like
what he's going to be called once he
gives the hat back to shanks and how
that connects both of these two
characters to the giant straw hat under
marijuana luffy's first mate zorro also
has conquerors haki it's constantly a
joke in the series that zorro seems like
he would be more capable of being
captain because of the air that he
carries himself with and that makes a
lot of sense considering that both of
them are conquerors zoro's dream isn't
to become king of the pirates though or
even captain instead he wants to become
the world's greatest swordsman so that
his name can become famous enough to
reach quina in heaven and of course
zorro's title is pirate hunter a
reference to his bounty hunting days in
the east blue yamato our newest
potential straw hat as of right now is
the child of kaido and was as such given
the title of oni princess namato's goal
is to be free similar to luffy however
this is in a much more literal sense
since they've always been trapped on
wano by kaido and now that kaido's been
defeated it looks like they might have
their chance to become free luffy's
brother ace also had conquerors he
originally wanted to become pirate king
himself but decided to put all of his
efforts into making whitebeard the
pirate king he was given the title fire
fists in reference to his devil fruit as
well as his signature attack eustis kid
is also aiming to become king of the
pirates however he seems to be the most
willing to do anything to reach that
goal while luffy aims to become pirate
king he tries to do things that are
morally good while he does so kid on the
other hand is willing to straight up
execute anyone in his way kid's epithet
is less than creative but he is called
eustis captain kid and our final canon
conqueror user is boa hancock the pirate
empress of amazon lily the captain of
the kuja pirates and the former warlord
hancock was a slave to the celestial
dragons early on in her life and has
made it her goal to rise above everyone
else so that she can never be looked
down on again hancock's titles are both
based on her position in amazon lily
being snake princess and pirate empress
and i've always kind of wondered how big
mom felt about her being called pirate
empress considering that big mom was one
of the four emperors and that title
likely would have made a lot more sense
for her but either way let's move on to
the final two members who are non-canon
users firstly niguri this is the old man
that trained luffy sabo and ace when
they were young he's a former pirate
captain who battled roger but was easily
defeated and we don't really know a lot
about him and i highly doubt we ever
will but when he left grey terminal his
dream of reuniting with his former crew
was reignited and finally we have
douglas bullet the former member of
rogers crew who was captured and kept an
impel down for 20 years until luffy's
great escape when he got out bullet set
himself on becoming pirate king and to
reach this goal we would even see him
taking on
this can't be right the script says he
took on everyone
uh one sec
[Music]
okay having just watched stampede for
the first time he did in fact take on
everyone
also the movie was pretty cool so check
it out if you haven't regardless for his
general ruthlessness and desire to
follow in his former captain's footsteps
bullet was given the title of demon air
and that's it we have officially covered
what conquerors is how it's used who can
use it and why those characters are
considered conquerors honestly this is a
really fun video to work on because
there's a lot of things i didn't really
notice about conkers in the past like
that the only non-pirate user is sengoku
or that if they aren't captains they
only work in the crews of other
conquerors users all really cool stuff
in my opinion but let me know what you
think in the comments and if you knew
those little details you can also let me
know if there's any other characters
that you think might have conquered that
we don't know about as always though if
you've enjoyed this video remember to
leave a like and a comment down below
letting us know what you thought and of
course if you aren't subscribed remember
to hit that button to stay up to date
with all the great content we have in
store for you finally you can follow us
over on twitter at anime uproar or you
can follow my own channel axel beats if
you're looking for more from me
personally with all that being said
though thank you so much for watching
and until next time remember to stay
excellent